think the best skate ever did you have
anything to do with like designing them
or anything I went to Portland Nike
headquarters and the first couple pairs
they made me were so big and boxy I was
like I can't play with those and I think
the guy who designed the Nike Air Jordan
shoes was the guy who was designing the
skate with me really and he came up with
this one finally and this is my favorite
skate award this was a good one yeah and
why did you have the blue blade I mean I
know these ones are black but so in Emon
they had perfected blade and took blade
and the T blade was black and I wanted
to be a little bit different I said can
you make me a blue one of these and they
said yeah so I always wore the blue
perfected just I don't know more it
worked yeah
worked did his job man this is cool how
are you